there i am i did that fall like eight
times yeah this this fight scene
definitely had people talking
thanks to today's sponsor squarespace
stay tuned to the end of the episode to
learn how to get 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain
guys welcome back to another episode of
stuntman react gee
dude it's so good to see you again man
yeah it's been so long i miss you man i
miss you too both of y'all yo what's up
guys my name is ghida silva green i am a
professional stuntman who is known for
his work in captain america civil war
along with some other cool stuff there
haven't been any productions for the
past three months there's been nothing i
finally get to see daylight
yeah we're gonna hop into some clips
here like i got a lot of fun stuff
prepped for you guys today let's get
started with one of my favorite kung fu
movies of all time hip man just to
clarify it's not like superman it's his
last name's like mon right come on yeah
okay
this was a story about a real guy
there's a guy who trained bruce lee this
was uh choreographed by samuel hung
right yeah really so if you guys know
samohang he's one of the three dragons
right you got jackie chan same oh hang
and you'll be out they all went to the
same you know school together
yeah so samo hung he's the one who
choreographed this whole movie he's in
it man too
i'm a huge fan of his choreography style
it's very clean it's very deliberate you
can see what's going on in the way it's
shot and covered is is it's impeccable
in my opinion
we got an intro fight one of the bad
guys rolling into town and he's gonna
beat up all of the kung fu masters so
they're challenging different styles
like my style's better than your style
yeah oh yeah why can't we live in a
world like that i want to live in a town
where it's like just martial arts
schools literally right across the
street from each other yeah
challenge you yeah
i'll be so happy that's i hope heaven's
like that
this shower here
the bounce back that's my favorite
my favorite move in that whole fight
sequence is that right there he bounced
him like a ball right there yeah
yeah yeah so that's wires that's like
sneaky wires right yes it is one of the
best people to show
that sneaky style of wire work is jackie
chan and all of his like old 80s stuff
like they use it just to amplify just
enough like they'll tag a leg and it's
when it's swept they they pull the leg
even harder just to make it look even
more violent and i think that's so fun
dude i love the closest to like just the
feet like hitting faces i've heard that
very frequently when they're doing shots
like that it's just somebody's arm and a
pant leg with a shoe on the handle we do
that all the time
it's actually very funny especially if
you don't have an extra pair of pants
you see a guy just standing no pants on
but his pants well he does have pants on
there
the samo trick is that he likes to use
those close-ups that way that he can
break a 180 at times
wait what do you mean by break the 180
and jump the line so there's certain
rules in film that you're supposed to
not break there's a rule about uh
breaking a line or the 180 where they
stay they're staying on the outside
right so like if me and g are fighting
right now we draw a line with our bodies
between us you're on one side of the
line nico's on the other side of the
line so as we're fighting if you were to
move the camera
over to niko's side and nico's filming
us that's a 180 degree move we had
jumped the line you're like whoa wait i
just teleported yes and now you have
motion sickness and you're confused you
you can't follow the rhythm of the fight
but they broke the line in this fight
and why did it work they go
really tight and show like a fist making
connection you can jump the line on
those close-ups because you you're out
of context it's just like close-up on
one guy at the fist coming in
my uh my buddy marcus his cousin they
own a sound design studio and they did
the sound design for this whole movie
what yeah that's really cool hong kong
yeah sound design can make or break a
fight without a doubt when you're
dealing with hits whether it's gunshots
bullet hits punches things like that
that sound only lasts for a frame
you know 24th of a second what gives it
power is its tail and its heads so you
know the lead-in is going to give you
that wind-up it's it's the breath you
take before like the shark attacks you
know
you know that sets you up for how
intense that hit's going to be so back
in the day when i started doing fight
scenes i was like oh cool i should do
whoosh noises before my punch noises you
know
it always sounded really bad
what i was doing wrong is i was using
air whooshes instead we needed this the
cloth
yes
you need to sound like your sleeve and
everything's like sliding against your
skin until that connects with that
impact you need that cloth
that punch for that punch to have power
because otherwise you just have a little
that's it
and that's that's that's nothing you
know like that doesn't sound powerful
but if you have a
you know all the sound effects stacked
on top you give that sound that single
punch a story it's like a set up in a
payoff you know like this thing's coming
in quick and you get popped and then
it's the repercussion of that the sound
design is there to tell a story yes and
then there's also like what type of
universe are you in because then the
sounds are different like the matrix has
a completely different sound than the
john wick
fun fact for the punch sounds in the
matrix they hit turkeys with baseball
bats not live turkeys
i want to show you one more fight from
ip man they basically they come in and
they force them to fight the japanese
set a little mini tournament to show off
their power and ip man's friends they
start dying and it man's like i gotta go
see for myself what's going on he's not
having it any
more
oh man so good the hype yeah this this
fight scene i think definitely had
people talking this was like pre-raid
and this is what everybody was talking
about pre-raid
gosh that looked that looked no he
really stepped off he really stepped on
him for sure what yeah that's a stomp
you know donnie was really hurting
people in this that i was hearing
stories from some of my friends that
they were saying yeah like donnie will
be like hey i'll give you an extra
couple hundred dollars if you let me
knock you out and and when it comes to
being a stuntman in china if you're not
on camera you don't get paid at all so
you could be sitting there all day in
costume waiting and not get shot and now
you are
not getting paid for that day you just
sat around and hung out i just want to
be the guy in the background just
holding his character stance the whole
time
i got him guys i got him on look see
so diana's like i'll give you a hundred
dollars
she's a really flexible dude or is it
dude without a leg nah it's there
there's definitely a fake leg in the
pants cause look look you see yeah you
can actually see his leg oh yeah you're
right he's just having his knee crazy
yeah you don't notice at all in motion
it works
machine gun blows
dude he's like his head is bouncing like
a freaking speed bag oh man he's
definitely making contact
maybe he's using hollow fist so it's
like so we make a fist and then we put
our thumb through
and then you have a hole yeah and then
you can it still looks like a fist yeah
but there's there's enough give
that you know i mean it's not going to
feel good regardless
i love it when they actually commit to
having four guys attack at once it's so
hard to choreograph for the stuff it is
so i mean in reality like how do you
fight four guys at once like well you
get hit
right at that moment
like what that's that's good timing by
the stunt guys and the actor who's
performing it because it's done ian when
daniel is using both arms and his leg at
the same time to fight all these dudes
oh wow yeah that's cool
two shouts to samuel
yeah seriously just this movie is solid
all the way around from the choreography
to the story that's why he can make four
oh my god they just got worse they got
so bad i saw three and i was like ah
is that the one mike tyson yeah what do
you mean
you see how tyson looks right now he's
jacked and he's boxing again you imagine
that coming after you that's 53 years
old
he's 53. if you guys have a scene with
some crazy stunts that you would love to
see a stuntman break down for you or
some woman please leave a comment down
below heck if there's a stuntman or
stunt woman you would love to have on
the show give us some suggestions we'll
reach out to them i thought you said if
there's a stuntman or some woman that
you would want to see on the show
i thought you said
[Music]
this is the finale to lucifer season 4
which i got to work on thanks to vlad
rimberg he's the choreographer fight
coordinator for the show
[Music]
what is going on there that's intense
like so he sets up for a cheat and then
he just opens himself up and then he
just gets push kick no wires no wires
damn you gotta do a real kick there yep
you gotta really get you got get really
hit andrew franklin taking it like a man
and oh damn it's good air awareness too
because he's spinning and he has to open
himself up at the right time in order to
get hit properly so that way he can hit
the ground correctly
i wouldn't come any closer if i were you
there there i am looking like i'm
supposed to be like kind of dead but not
dead
dude this guy with his double blocks was
incredible so dude so karate
i did that fall like
eight times oh sometimes they they
wanted tom ellis to be a little bit
closer so i ended up having to do it
multiple times and then you had like the
gator back no i didn't i didn't have a
gator back oh my gosh
yeah i just was taking it landing on my
back
i've done it so many times that i kind
of can just control myself to the point
where i'm a hit where i want to hit tom
ellis does the thing where he double
claps my ears he was really clapping my
ears really dude like that's not really
like just gah god and of course
everybody's laughing at me while this is
happening because they know i'm in pain
that'll actually like cause some serious
damage yeah absolutely so be careful
when you guys do that don't aim at the
ears go either i would say behind the
ears i don't even think they
made it in the cut and that's what hurts
so much you do all this work
and it's it gets cut out sometimes
because it doesn't fit pacing or they
need to cut time for the film for for
whatever it is that they're trying to do
right
that's amy johnston really yeah
this is everybody we know pretty much it
looks like it was cheated a little bit
here with this cut right there yeah but
it actually flows yeah i think it like
you still have that rotational movement
that cuts really nice into the next shot
so and then she just gets destroyed
the vertical power punch yeah just like
god
that's such a cool move dude like
throwing weapons
shad gaspard he's a former wwe superstar
from crime the group crime time he
actually recently just passed away he
was
in the ocean
at venice beach and
the riptides got him and he saved his
son
no way man oh this is so rough check gas
part art man big bro
rest in peace man
[Music]
so i got i got one last clip for you
guys i want to bring it all the way back
to 1973. oh yeah it's actually the year
bruce lee passed away this is his last
complete movie we're talking about enter
the dragon guys
oh
boom i love the fake out you don't see
that a lot anymore i know like that's a
true strategy in fighting
what was his plan there i don't know
what his plan i don't know
maybe he was going for the dragon kick
the flying sidekick and he's like i'm
not going to get my leg cut so i'll just
take it across the abs because they're
steel here it comes i'm gonna go again
and that looked like an actual foot i
think that was a real foot
oh you know who choreographed this
samo no no no
no way
he was the coordinator on this what yeah
are you serious yeah he's in the he's
the opening fight that's samuel hung
you didn't know that
yum yum is the acrobat double for bruce
no way cause i know jackie chan's in
this yeah they're all in it because of
samo samo is the one who brought them
all into stunts and this was one of the
first films that they all worked on
that's freaking awesome
yo this kick though
that was a doll yeah and that dawn
the dude is dead
that is a car crash right there it
scares me how powerful that is there was
barely any hip turn in that kick too
which makes it even more scarier most
people when they kick through they they
take from the muay thai
and it it goes all the way across so
most of the time you'll end up throwing
a round kick and you'll spin all the way
back around 360. his his hips go at most
45 like it's there and then comes right
back so he's he's fighting it and
bringing it all the way back at the end
of that instead just letting it flow all
the way through so he keeps himself in
camera in frame you see his face the
whole time so to have that much power
while also then applying the brakes
right so much control man that's ab work
pure core that makes that possible well
i mean bruce lee is just entirely a core
yeah he's just abs yeah
i mean this is technically what would
happen today if dana white created fight
island which is literally the start of
how why han yeah is where han is yeah he
has this island no guns allowed there
only martial artist sounds like heaven
that's the engine of the dragon remake
yeah five islands created by the ufc
[Laughter]
hey guys i'm out here training again
working on my next stunt reel because
after the last ones that i did on the
stuntman reacts videos i booked a gig
that's right now granted it was for my
uncle's car dealership but it doesn't
really matter because i still booked a
gig this whole endeavor was made
possible because of my squarespace page
and i'm going to show you how if you
guys are interested in starting a new
endeavor this year i mean 2020 what the
heck squarespace is the perfect thing to
get you started so i'm out here to train
again and to do another stunt reel to
make a good stunt reel you don't need to
go to a gym all you need is a nice open
field and a beautiful tree much like
squarespace's beautiful award-winning
templates now this tree overhangs the
field and from it you can see everything
much like squarespace's traffic
overviews tools which allow you to see
who comes to your site
through squarespace's multiple
contributors tools you can give
different people different levels of
access on your site depending on who
they are and what their needs are
through squarespace's simultaneous
posting tool you can leapfrog over the
painstaking process of posting the same
thing on multiple social media platforms
you post it one time on your website
through squarespace and it automatically
formats and goes out to your other
social media profiles that's real great
squarespace also has an audioblocks
feature that allows you to post podcasts
on your site and automatically serve as
an rss feed going out on all podcast
distribution platforms oh yeah
well i think that's about enough content
for my next stunt reel but if you guys
are interested in starting a new
endeavor of your own make it 2020 make
it squarespace because god only knows
what's going to happen the rest of this
year but one thing's for sure you can
get 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain by going to squarespace.com
corridor crew that's squarespace.com
corridor crew
guys thank you so much for sticking
around and joining us gee it was amazing
to have you on the show dude follow ghee
on instagram if you have not he has some
awesome stuff ask him some questions
maybe he'll respond who knows
i tried to man i'm asked the same
question over and over again how do you
become a stunt man how do you become a
[ __ ] man i would say the best thing to
do is find the closest area a hub
atlanta new york los angeles go to the
gyms that have open gym try to meet some
people there's a whole bunch of people
online that are around you can try to
see if you can go where they where they
train or where they work out start
working on your falls there's a bunch of
videos online that show you the basic
falls the first couple jobs you're going
to do
is going to be throwing a right hook
missing getting punched in the face ouch
that hurt and then you're hitting the
ground so get good at doing those three
things and more than likely you'll start
working your way towards being a stem
person thank you guys for watching if
you guys have cool clips please leave a
comment down below also subscribe if
you're not and stick around guys because
we got videos like this coming out every
single week so i'll see you guys next
time